cocomelon diss track sl did you watch it
did you like it of course you did
amazing i'm really proud of it i thought
it was really cool it was a fun product
to work on i just wanted to make it
clear before i start this video by
saying that
you know i saw this as the finale i saw
this as you know ending the meme we've
been doing the
the coco style intros and all that stuff
which has been really fun but you know
i'm not going to continue with it
because number one
it would just not be funny and number
two i don't actually care about coco man
like if any if anyone ever passes me in
the future i'm not going to make a whole
spiel out of it uh it was fun for what
it was and number three i don't i don't
want it to get out of control like it
did last time so
just want to be clear keep it civil keep
it fun
and um yeah that's it i do have some
other music projects coming up that are
not
diss tracks that i'm really excited
about so i really appreciate all the
support i'm glad you guys like the music
and i'm just really excited to do
something different to uh
do more of it but that's it roll the
intro
[Music]
[Music]
anyway let's get into the memes your dog
is not in heaven he is rotten in the
yard
everyone the kid
[Music]
oh man the kids are such good actors and
actresses it was so uh impressive fun
working with kids it sounds weird but um
yeah they were great we had such a good
time i'll probably do like a behind the
scenes video
later this week because it was a strange
experience to say the least
especially during covet lockdown to do a
production there was all these crazy
regulations and
yeah well i'll get into that in another
video crazy regulations for a good
reason by the way but it's just
a bizarre experience as a result uh your
dog is not in heaven he's rotten in the
yard edgar in the other room no
iggy did you notice the jojo referencing
the video
it was so epic your audience is just a
bunch of mother freaking virgins
maybe i am a coco
nothing wrong with being a virgin hey
i'll say it but i'm also stating the
fact
i knew there were going to be memes for
the kids i knew it that's fantastic
damn all right two-year-old starting
early now huh okay
it's working it's working subscribe
how old do you have to be to have a
youtube account doesn't matter clearly
for cocoa melon
i like how so many people have problem
with me swearing in front of kids
and you have people playing the songs
for their kids
for the record i didn't swear in front
of kids we had censored version on set
stop crying you're a bunch of cry babies
boy in a ben
was a good boy until he wasn't i'm so
glad the day was part of the video so
fun
felix coming to my wedding buying a
couple of gym
hell yeah listen that's hilarious that
was so fun having you know
hey man that was great when you lost
your house after two hours of exploring
no this is why i always build my house
at my spawn because then you die you die
which i won't anyway but it don't matter
no more oh it's burrito glasses oh god
no
[Music]
hey burrito i don't want to see this
i'll reach
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
why did i say i was gonna reach out and
i forgot i'm sorry
[Music]
the damn tweet no
no i just realized no no
[Music]
no
[Music]
for another music video it'd be really
cool actually to get a deep fake i would
love to work with you but it's just
everything's gotten delayed i think
that's why i was going to reach out
remember that workout binge
pewds america's cheapest family also
pewds
sick i'm not cheap it's honestly it's
very liberating to be able to move your
work out anywhere you go
like myanmar said when camping for a
week i could just literally bring my
dumbbells and
do the exact same routine which felt
really good
you can't lose the gains bro just cuz
you're on holiday ain't happening
ain't happening obviously i will expand
my my
uh my gym it's just that i'm also moving
hopefully
at some point in my goddamn life great
job youtube
just for the record i don't hate kids
but as a
why do i always have to state such
obvious jokes i feel like uh what is
this he brought a smite
five sword with him but he decided to
use an axe instead
you can kill the wither in like five
hits if you crate with a smite
v and strength too someone gotta put
this in the y
someone gotta put this in the y
oh oh really oh really
oh really you backseat gaming
[ __ ]
all right all right let's check my my
sword
in minecraft let me book that so many
times
people tell me the wrong sh in minecraft
oh just you wait that's my sword oh
what's that it has sharpness on it not
smite
five oh was that my access might fire on
it
so i was right to use my axe incredible
god apologize apologize now
mr bismarck or i'll make it this on
markiplier
yeah you thought 69 was the only one
caught in the crossfire dirt block
exists enderman and i took that
so god damn annoying when you're trying
to build a symmetrical structure
in dirt i'm changing it you enderman
felix heals multiple times
felix when the wither heals itself you
are truly the lowest come in history hey
they got it right i used the axe huh
what did these
what does this mean making get it right
what the hell for those
of you minecraft noobs that don't
understand
simple fundamentals in minecraft smite
does more damage on skeletons and is
better than sharpness in general
but i guess some people just don't know
that i'm on a break i'm back with a huge
announcement i can't believe he's back
after nine years sorry guys
just went on a little breakaroo
i swear to you this is not intentional
just so you know
but that's a great even though in the
clothing dude what the hell
[Laughter]
my cows are loving me because i'm
holding weed me who needs 45 books for
my enchanting room i literally just did
this because i needed
item frames and i didn't feel sorry for
a second how do you do a vegan
play-through like
how do you get that much leather huh huh
explain this mo jang hey you don't care
about environment
true true he punched hard he just
brofisted my face
nothing unusual the parents who let
their kids take part of the
this music video are god tier hell yeah
i never got to see them because uh
of uh kobe that few people is possible
on set
but uh thank you parents remind me to
never become a rapper hey you liked all
the videos though
you liked all of them there's also
exciting news
more music coming up gamers the boss
when you fight him
that that's really unlucky much playable
character can i just get a huge shout
out to everyone i thought it was so cool
that actual fans of the channel got to
work on
on stuff like armor and stuff like that
uh guys go give cosplay shops
like style some love yeah becky osborne
did the helmet and the sword
so so [ __ ] cool yeah it was just like
a really great collaboration i i really
enjoyed it all the costume design on set
the beat itself the kids they the
directors of the music video it just all
came out perfectly i'm so i'm so glad
you guys liked it it's not really my
style to put more
production into things in general that's
not what i do i just say hey we want to
[ __ ] up to the beach and just film me
play around my arms for a bit which has
worked in the past but i
i wanted this to be something fun and
cool for you guys so for the fans
for the bros for the nine-year-olds
complete leg workout no equipment do i
have legs like that see this
oh oh what even is that
all right i'm not on that level yet i
want to be on the level where it looks
like you have a dick in your leg
okay i can't be the only one who saw
that okay shut up hey
you got some references nice i thought i
thought the american psycho reference
like yeah that's a bit on the nose maybe
but everyone's like i
i know that fun fact one of the kids
were so good at playing
uh sad that uh we just had to cut it
because it looked too horrific and i
will say delivering those lines
in front of the kids was not
a pleasant experience it's like yeah you
wrote these lines now you have to pay
the consequences
they had a great time by the way okay
just so we're clear they were just
laughing i don't even think they were
listening
i wanted to make a video to thank felix
people
usually say and it's true that we are
here because
everything every single little thing
that happened in our lives
and it's true but felix is the one that
if he wasn't there i wasn't here too he
posted a video called
five reasons not to give us and
that video really
is my everything i was in a very dark
place it was a time where
nothing really mattered to me i would
wake up every day
and the only thing that made me go
through the day was
waiting to come home to watch pewdiepie
he was
like the only reason that kept me going
for for a long time but one day
it wasn't enough just waiting to see
more
from him so it was
so special hearing him making a video
telling that everything would be fine
and
you know that life would be back
together and
and that he
so hearing him say everything's going to
be fine i promise
really was really everything to me
damn so i just wanted to put this here
because i think it's very important that
people know that they are important so
that's nice that's why i'm doing this
and
yes felix is my yellow person everything
is going to be fine yellow person i've
never heard of that
fight through it which i know you can no
it will be worth it
i'll always be here oh damn that's crazy
i don't even remember this video but
that
this video is so lovely um i'm so glad
oh
that's so sweet
yeah i guess i never seen my videos as
that clearly because i don't even
recollect making this video but uh i'm
glad it had an impact that's crazy i
think it's always good to remind
yourself things
you know you go through bad days or bad
times but it will get better and
especially when you're growing up that
is such a tough period
that i think most people struggle with
obviously some some more some less but
it is a matter of fact so it is 100 true
that things will get better so hang in
there gamers
it will be worth it feel free like see
behind the scenes of making coco it's
coming
it's coming
soon thank you guys so much for all the
support on the video i'm so glad you
liked it i know
there's a lot of expectations because
lasagna was so cute and
and i get it or people are always going
to compare but i'm really proud of it
and i'm happy what it is so i'm glad you
guys
enjoy it too moving on to the next one
prepare yourself just uh big thanks guys
appreciate you
see you guys profess